bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors depuis le début de
l'année ont à peu près une cinquantaine
d'attaqués qui ont été menées contre des
intérêts américains
pourquoi leur fréquence est accrue ces
derniers jours
tout simplement parce que les tailles
ration malheureusement n'a pas le
monopole de la violence
et parce que aussi la relation irano
américain se dégrade sur le terrain
irakien
vous savez ces milices qui conduisent
ces attaques contre les intérêts
américains mais aussi contre les
partenaires américains et les
partenaires des occidentaux sur le sol
irakien
ces milices sont téléguidés orienté par
téhéran et nous pas par bagdad par la
république islamique de l'iran et nous
pas par l'état tire à sion et de
chauffer plus la relation américano
iranien ne se dégrade plus la quantité à
la quantité et l'intensité de ses
attaques contre les intérêts américains
mais aussi les intérêts communs des pays
du système international augmente alors
est ce que finalement l'irak
c'est le terrain d'une guerre qui ne lui
appartient pas alors moi je j'emploie
palomo de guerre je pense
personnellement que les américains et
les etc les iraniens qui sont à la
recherche d'une formule et c'est à dire
quoi c'est à dire depuis l'arrivée de
joe biden à la maison blanche
il y a une forte volonté américaines
d'inclure la république islamique d'iran
mais aussi l'arabie saoudite la france
et bien d'autres pays même la turquie a
dans ce que j'appelle la co gestion du
dossier irakien les américains
vous savez déjà son entrée dans une
phase de désengagement et ceux des
engagements sur le terrain irakien ne
doit pas souffert
comme sur le terrain afghan combien
afghans en afghanistan comme on vient de
le voir d'en voir un reportage
les américains ne souhaite pas laisser
derrière eux un vide
invité à livrer totalement la république
ira irakienne à l'iran pour cela ils
sont la négociation pour trouver une
formule et pendant cette négociation là
les américains comme les iraniens
mettent de la pression
l'un sur l'autre les ans sur l'autre
afin de d'imposer leurs propres
conditions à cette formule qui n'est pas
encore trouvé alors justement vous en
parlions et négociations à vienne sur le
nucléaire iranien
alors est ce que ces attaques actuelles
en irak peuvent avoir des conséquences
sur les actuelles négociations en cours
sur le nucléaire iranien tout et tout
est ensemble et tout et tout ces
éléments de la population à nucléaire y
ait ce qui se passe au yémen en syrie au
liban en irak
tous ces éléments là tous ces pays n'a
toutes ces problématiques constitue à un
cadre général de négociations avec la
république islamique d'où les rangs si
par exemple la lada si la
déstabilisation de l'irak vient depuis
ses milices augmente à et d'où vient un
fait tangible pomelo quai d'orsay l'a
bien remarqué la condamner un
alors bien évidemment ces états vont
agir directement et indirectement sur la
négociation en cours mais pas seulement
en irak mais aussi en syrie ruia manon
les bandes dans tous ces pays là mais
parcours pour tout parent de l'irak
parce que tous en peu de mois
l'irak est au coeur du hainaut l'irak
n'est pas blue liban n'est pas la série
n'est pas le yémen cherchent un des pays
des grands pays du moyen orient la
déstabilisation du pays qui est déjà
déstabilisé suffisamment à la dé
sécurisation de ce pays là le
démantèlement de ce pays-là va bien
évidemment agir sur la totale et du
moyen orient
et pas seulement sur les pays voisins
alors on parle beaucoup à donner
des états unis mais en tout cas ça se
passe sur le sol irakien où on sont
actuellement les autorités irakiennes
est ce qu'elles nous ont réellement une
marge de manoeuvre bah écoutez vous avez
malheureusement des institutions
étatiques présent on piège en otage je
dirais même un par ces organisations
milicienne il faut juste rappeler qu'on
ira que vous avez 75 organisations
milicienne qui dispose 165 mille
combattants qui a qui ont un budget de
12 milliards et demi de dollars juste
pour cette année là et ces organisations
milicienne qui dispose des hélicoptères
des chars des droits ils sont elles sont
beaucoup plus fortes que l'armée
irakienne
leurs appareils de ceux qui auraient
qu'elles sont beaucoup plus solides
beaucoup plus puissants que les
appareils sécuritaires 12 l'état irakien
je dirais malheureusement à l'état
irakien est trop faible pour pouvoir
agir et réagir par rapport à ces
organisations milicienne baconnes merci
en tout cas d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur du centre français de
recherche sur l'irak marciac